hello my name is Peter and given away I
wonder about the synergy between the
nanotechnology and the biotechnology how
do you see that will progress in the
coming 10 years and we can you give some
examples be pathetic you know what you
think will happen in 15 years so time
from now yeah the synergy comes from the
common tools and finally what are the
nanotechnology this is a several many
tools that now can be used by the
physicist by the chemist by a so by the
biologist and so for example and so this
tools prepare mainly by the physicists
can be extend to a self field and for
exam for the and biotech you can use a
proximity microscope for exam STM used
before by the physicists you can use
also by your ships fabricate on the same
with the same methods are the ships of
the electrician's or you can use also
the techniques of micro 3d t2 for
example to survive fluids in analysis
device and so this is this in facts now
many fields of research share these
tools were called the nano technologies